CHET HAASE: Hello, and
welcome to Material Science,
or what you might also
call-- no, no, no, no, no.
Let's do that again.
Material Design for
Android Developers.
The point of this
session is to try
to get into some of
the technical details
and the overview
of what it actually
looks like from an
engineer's perspective.
There's a lot of design
sessions this week,
including one right
before this session where
they talk about some of the
ideas behind material design.
What we wanted to do
is talk about what
that means in terms of the
actual APIs we're exposing
or where you hook into this
stuff as an Android developer
to create material
design applications.
There's a hashtag, if you
like to do that thing.
There's a feedback URL.
If you have absolutely
stunning and glowing comments
about the session, please
feel free to go there.
If you want to know
what we look like,
you could actually just
look up at the stage,
or there's pictures
of us I am Chet Haase.
ADAM POWELL: And
I am Adam Powell.
CHET HAASE: And we are both on
the Android UI Toolkit Team.
This is the team that basically
handles the UI Toolkit widgets,
down through the graphics that
render them with animations
that move them around
and spitting at the GPU
commands to actually hardware
accelerate all this stuff
and get onto the screen
as fast as possible.
That's what the team
does, which means
that all the stuff that we
need to implement for material
design also needs
to run really fast,
because the same team is
handling the functionality as
well as the performance aspects,
which is an interesting trade
off.
ADAM POWELL: So
the first question
that you might be
asking is, why?
So we've already seen
the keynote videos.
We see a lot of flashy effects.
We see high-minded design.
We see performance challenges.
And we see a way to
really bloat our UIs.
So we don't actually
want to take
that negative view of this.
We want to make sure
that this is something
that really matters
to our users.
And if there's one big takeaway
from all of the material design
material that you're going to
see over the rest of the day
and for probably
until the L release
here as everyone starts
getting their apps ready,
is that motion matters.
Movement can teach a user
what something can do
and where it came from.
If you've ever seen
in a UI something
just pop out of
nowhere, something
disappears from out
from under your finger.
That's a really
frustrating experience.
So by using motion, we can
go ahead and teach users
how the system
behaves and what they
can expect from that system.
So this is cues.
We can give cues about what
can be touched and moved
by making things
that look tangible.
This is one of the things
that cards really give us.
And these sorts
of virtual objects
that can morph and move around
in ways that don't quite
simulate real world objects, can
still hint at that tangibility.
These are your cards,
paper, and ink.
All these things that you've
seen in the video so far.
So the takeaway really is
motion plus tangibility equals
a more understandable
UI for your users.
CHET HAASE: So I
wanted to give you
a brief mental model of what
this release and this process
of actually implementing
material design was to me.
Actually, making this
work within our team,
getting the stuff,
the pixels actually
showing up on the screen
that represents the design.
The process is basically
taking the ideas
that UX has-- that the
design team has-- where
they're these grand ideas
and there's paradigms,
and there's systems,
and there's languages,
and there's all this nice
stuff that they come up with,
and then actually translate
it into the technical details
of the functionality
that engineers actually
need to write applications
that are going to deliver that.
So the way I picture it-- so
we had this huge design team
so we have access
to great artists
and we could ask them to come
up with art that represents this
or I could actually
just draw it myself.
This obviously is an artist
waving his hands furiously
and coming up with beautiful
rainbows and wonderful things.
You can tell it's an
artist, because there's
a beret involved either
that or their French.
So we take the design ideas--
they're floating up in the air
and incredibly vague when
engineers get in the room
and get really puzzled
look on their face,
wondering what
all this stuff is.
When they say language in
the context of application
it doesn't make sense.
So then--
ADAM POWELL: It
means Java, right?
CHET HAASE: I think so.
I think it means the Java
programming language.
We'll talk to the US team
after this and nail that down.
But the idea really is to
take the concrete elements
and figure out
what they actually
mean by all the hand waving when
they're talking about floating
action buttons, when they're
talking about ink and paper
and actually translating it
into the particular elements
that we need in the platform
to give you those capabilities.
The way I think
of it is-- I think
it's like the Nyquist Sampling
Theorem says that there's
a frequency at which you
can sample a curve such
that you can then reconstruct
the original curve.
And I won't get into
technical details
because I don't understand them.
But it's the same idea here.
If UX is creating this
beautiful, spatial curve
of the design language and the
pattern they're coming up with.
And what you want
to do is implement
enough functionality
that they actually
get what they wanted even though
they had a hard time describing
it in terms of the crisp
elements that you needed.
So what we did on
the toolkit team
was to translate that into the
features and the functionality
that we needed to expose
those capabilities.
And this boiled
down to the features
that we're going to talk
about in the next few minutes.
We have the ability to
do real time shadows.
We have activity transitions
with shared hero elements.
We have circular reveals.
We saw some of that
in the design talks
as the floating
action buttons are
revealing into larger
morphed content.
We have RecyclerView widgets
for more animated and rich list
capabilities, touch
feedback so the user has
constant feedback about
what's going on in the UI
as they're interacting with it.
And then obviously we're working
on performance all the time
as well.
ADAM POWELL: So
from all of this,
how do you actually
write a material app?
Well, the first
step is something
that you're probably already
familiar with in writing
Android apps is your
theme for your activities.
So theme.material
is the first step.
Choose this.
Inherit from it,
if you've already
got a custom theme that you're
using other elements in.
And just take a look.
How does your app look with
this simple switch flip?
And you're going to need to
make some spots fixes to that.
Pretty much every major app
that's nontrivial at this point
has done a lot of work
to try to match either
a hollow theme or
a very custom theme
that's been implemented
in the past.
And you're going
to need to update
those individual
elements as you go.
So you'll want to go ahead
and implement the design
guidelines.
So this is going to
be new ways of dealing
with layouts and colors, new
metrics, new measurements,
and use of the grid.
From there, it's really mostly
standard Android programming.
You're going to be
using a lot of the tools
that you're already
familiar with there.
We've got some new
API is to assist
with motion and alignment of
certain elements on screen
that you traditionally
haven't had a lot of control
over in the past,
such as where things
are positioned in
the action bar.
And then, of course, you can use
the support library as needed.
Most of you are familiar
with this already.
We've got things like
DrawerLayouts, ViewPager,
all these widgets
that's developers
know and love at this point.
We're adding in some more.
We've got RecyclerView,
which we're
going to talk a little
bit more about shortly,
and card view, which
basically wraps up
a few of these pieces of
new functionality in L,
and gives you a nice fall
back for a particular use
case on older platform versions.
So then, as needed,
you can go ahead
and use some of the exclusive
L APIs for newer platform
versions as well.
This is stuff like
newer graphics APIs
around shadows and clipping,
setting elevation on your views
so that they can
pop out into space.
We've got the touch
feedback ink ripples
that you've seen in some
of the videos so far.
We've got icons and
other drawables.
You can animate state changes.
If you're already used to
pressed states and focus
states, so and so forth.
You can define
animated transitions
between those states now.
And as for general animations,
we've got view reveals.
We have new ways of dealing
with animation curves,
and of course, the activity
transitions that you've seen.
So at this point, most
of you are asking,
what about compatibility?
Because no one has the
luxury of targeting only
L and above right now.
If you want to have
some users when this
thing ships.
So for apps on
previous releases,
use the app compat themes.
You may already be
familiar with these
from using the compatibility
action bar in the support
library.
We're going to be
expanding this out to also
cover the material design
components in L. You can,
of course, still use
the new support library
widgets regardless, like
RecyclerView, CardView,
and the others that
you know and love.
CHET HAASE: So now let's talk
about some of the new APIs
and functionality that we
exposed in the UI toolkit.
One of the important points
that Adam was talking about
is you can get a lot of
functionality of the design
that you're trying to achieve
just through standard Android
programming by which we mean
the APIs that you're already
using-- standard
layout and measurement
stuff, standard drawing stuff.
We did add new APIs.
Most of the reason they're is
actually for our internal use.
So we have the ability
to pop a view up,
to give it elevation above
the view hierarchy plane.
But we use this for some
of the standard widgets.
You don't necessarily need to
use these for your application.
But they are there for
your use if you want them.
So one of those
areas is actually
widgets, which this
is not new L APIs.
It's in fact even
better than that.
It's new support web APIs.
ADAM POWELL: Right.
So again you have access to
this from everything from API 7
and above we have
both RecyclerView
and CardView available
for you to take
a look at early in the preview.
So what is RecyclerView?
You've heard a lot
about this now.
It's a base class for
new adapter-backed views.
Basically, anyone who's
tried to do anything remotely
interesting or complicated
with a list view at this point
has banged their head
against a lot of walls,
hanging beams, sharp
objects, whatever
you might want to use as
your metaphor for that.
And basically,
list view is set up
to take complete
and total control
over the layout of items,
pretty much any time it wants.
So you look at it funny
and everything relays out.
All your animations are lost.
Views that were halfway
through an animation
are now halfway off screen,
bound to some other data item.
And it's really frustrating
as a developer to try and use
that to get any sort of
really rich experience.
It's really outgrown
its complexity budget
in a lot of ways.
So RecyclerView is meant
to have more flexible views
into these large data sets
that you would traditionally
use a ListView for.
We've already built
in functionality
to allow an adapter to tell the
widget a bit more about what's
going on with the data set when
items are specifically added
or removed or when
ranges of items
are specifically
added or removed.
Rather than just saying,
hey, my data set changed.
Well, what changed?
I don't know.
You figure it out.
So in this way, we're
able to give you
a few more things automatically,
such as animations when items
are added or removed
from the set.
CHET HAASE: If I could avoid
creating one more tutorial
on how to animate something
in an adapter view,
I will be happy.
ADAM POWELL: So
that's the idea here.
So we also allow you
to do custom layouts
in this framework.
Many of you have said, OK.
Well, ListView is
great, but what
if I wanted to
scroll horizontally?
What if I want the
dividers to behave
just a little bit different?
What if I want a staggered
grid that doesn't necessarily
line up along particular lines?
So we offer that.
We offer multi-directional
scrolling.
Basically, you as the developer
can plug-in your own layout
manager to define how
item views get laid out.
This speaks to the general
theme of RecyclerView, which is,
to make it extensible in all
the ways that ListView really
wasn't.
We also have CardView.
Now, CardView takes a little
bit of a different approach
from RecyclerView.
RecyclerView is meant to be
a very generalized component
that you can go
ahead and build on.
Whereas CardView is
meant to be something
that solves a very
particular use case in a way
that is compatible, and gives
you a best effort approximation
of the design intent on
different platforms versions.
So in this case, we'll give
you a standard consistent look.
You get the real soft shadows
and customized rounded view
clipping for your rounded
corners and such on L,
and we'll go ahead and give
you a best effort fake version
and shape background pre L. But
as you can see from the slides
up here, these actually
look pretty similar in terms
of giving you the general
intent of the design.
So this type of tools
is the sort of thing
that we want to provide more
of, to allow you to express
material design on
older platform versions.
CHET HAASE: So now let's
talk about the other side,
the APIs and
functionality that's
actually in the L platform.
The previous stuff was
in support library.
Feel free to use it
wherever it makes
sense for your application.
If you're targeting
certain functionality
for your application,
specifically at L,
then you have access to the
new API that we introduced.
First of all, let's
talk about shadows.
So here is an early
video that the UX group
did as they were exploring
the space of what they wanted
the shadows to actually be like.
So we can watch this.
Let's see if it runs.
So we have the light source.
Notice it's an
area light source.
We have an orthographic
projection for the camera,
looking straight down.
And then we have cards
doing complicated things,
casting these nice,
real-time dynamic shadows.
And all the
engineers responsible
for implementing something like
this in 60 frames a second just
had a heart attack
ADAM POWELL: Or
sometimes laughed.
CHET HAASE: So here's
my favorite video mock
that came out of the design
team during the entire release.
A couple of the
engineers, they were
working on early prototypes
of the shadow stuff,
went over to talk
to the design team.
And as they were talking to
them about the requirement
for having this
area light source--
and maybe it should be rounded,
maybe it should be rectangular.
We definitely want
rounded corners
and soft shadows
and all this stuff.
Obviously, it has to perform
at the 60 frames a second rate.
In the background was a
high-end workstation running
high-end animation software
rendering this-- one
single frame in 30 seconds and
they wanted 60 frames a second
on a phone.
It's just so painful.
You can even tell where
the shadows are there,
and it's still taken this
long to render the thing.
And we're wondering how to
actually do that in real time.
And then I guess we figured out.
So the idea behind
shadows is to allow
you to elevate your views, to
post those views above the view
hierarchy plane.
So you can think of everything
prior to L living in a volume,
if you will, except everything
was at z equals zero.
Everything is in
that same plane.
It's basically the
flat land of Android.
Well, in the L
release, we allow you
to then boost some of
those views at your option
with an elevation
or a translation z
value or a z value to
basically give them
a z value that puts them
above the plane of everyone
else in that flat land.
And that allows them to
then automatically cast
the shadow from the
aerial light source
that we have positioned
locally above that world.
One other advantage
of doing it this way,
instead of just trying
to figure out, OK.
Well, how can we quickly
draw this shadow image
behind this thing and make it
look approximately correct?
One advantage of doing it
correctly in the view volume
approach is that views can also
draw outside of their container
bounds.
I don't know if you've
ever tried to draw a view,
like cast a shadow
or scale the view up,
and all of a sudden it
scales or it casts outside
of its containment hierarchy,
then it gets clipped.
And then you have to play
around with this API called
setClipChildren(false).
And things kind of go not
the way you expected them to,
and it's all a horrible hack.
So instead of doing
hacks, we're actually
doing it physically correctly.
We're creating this 3D volume.
You can boost views
up there, and they
can draw wherever they
want to in that volume.
And their correct ordered in z.
They draw in the correct order.
And the shadows draw in the
correct order below them
on top of the view
hierarchy itself.
ADAM POWELL: In addition
to that, many of you
have probably run into
cases where you really
do want to have a proper
z order for your views
when you start stacking them.
In the past, you've had to
override the child ordering
parameters for drawing.
In the past, you may
have also just abused
the general child ordering
within a view group
in order to achieve
the desired effect,
and this gives you a very easy
way to skip all of that hassle.
CHET HAASE: So we
can look at some
of the APIs involved
with doing this.
There is basically the
elevation property.
This is where that thing lives.
You can think of this as
its permanent z location.
And we have a couple
of other properties
that are similar to the
translation x and translation y
properties.
Though, these are more
for use in animation,
transient post
layout state where
you're animating to and
from different z values.
So for instance, if you have a
view that you want to pop up,
you want that shadow to enlarge
when it's in a press state,
then you would animate the
translation z property,
whether or not it had a
positive elevation value.
There's also other
APIs we're not
showing on the slide
about clipping.
So you can set the shape
of the shadow itself.
So you can think of
floating action buttons
as being this circular shape.
Well, they want to
cast a circular shadow.
Otherwise, the
illusion breaks down.
So there are APIs to allow
you to set the shape that it
casts the shadow from.
There are also APIs to
allow you to set an outline
that it's actually clipped to.
Some of this necessarily,
given the constraints
that we're operating
under, are very limited.
You can't clip to arbitrary path
shapes, so some of the details
are in the SDK Docs.
And also the APIs around
clipping and specifically
are probably apt to change as
we go toward the full release,
but you can see where
we're at in the preview
release in the meantime.
Let's run a demo, so we can
see how this thing works.
So if we can switch to
the demo-- here we go.
You can see, next to
my very red finger,
I can drag this card around.
And I can actually enable tilt.
You can get a subtle
tilt on this thing.
I think there's even a
little bit of shading, which
is probably way too subtle
for these projectors.
So you can see this in fact
is not an artist's rendering.
And it's not taking
30 seconds a frame.
So we got 60 frames a second
on-- this is a Nexus 5.
Actually a lot of
the early work was
done on older and
slower devices.
I think the original Nexus 7 was
used as a prototype device just
to make sure that
things were actually
going to be fast enough.
And again, this is
an area light source
for any of the graphics
geeks in the room, area light
source local.
There's a lot of
assumptions you can make,
if it was a point source
and it was infinite.
And we're not making
those assumptions here.
We're actually creating
these meshes in real time
to cast shadows with
soft boundaries,
because that's the
effect that they wanted.
So works reasonably well.
There's another one
I was going to show.
Let see, Shadow Card Stack.
So you can see these
stacking elements
as they're popped up
to different z values.
And they cast larger
or smaller shadows
just as you would expect in
this physically correct volume.
ADAM POWELL: And this
demo really illustrates
some of the other
facts that you may
have seen during
the keynote demo
as well, which is you
can have elements that
are part of the
same merged plane,
split and take on more of a
three dimensional character
as you interact with them.
CHET HAASE: If we can
switch back to the slides.
There it is.
Yeah.
Let's talk about touch feedback.
Sure.
Let's talk about ripples.
So one of the things
that we wanted
to do in the UI in
general-- actually,
we were thinking about it
in the engineering space,
before we were faced with
the overall design language
changes for material
design-- is the ability
to tell the user more
of what's going on
with their UI interactions.
In particular, when
they press a button,
there is that immediate atomic
interaction where the button is
in a pressed state, so they
get pressed state color.
That's nice.
But wouldn't it be
nice if we could
animate some of those changes
so they get information
about the changing states, sort
of a time-based change in state
as well as more information
about where that state actually
changed?
So ripples do that.
The touch feedback interaction
on the standard widgets
and on your custom widgets,
if you choose to enable it,
gives you feedback
about a pressed state
happening or other
states happening,
so the ripple will
sort of emanate.
Not only that, but it
will emanate optionally
from the point of contact.
So you can get a
ripple that actually
starts from where
the finger pressed.
So much more
interaction information
for the user to actually
understand what's going on.
ADAM POWELL: And again,
just to speak again
to the principle of motion
and how that's really
sort of helping
understand the UI
this eliminates a lot
of the really disruptive
flashing that you
see in UIs today
where you get the entire wrecked
of the touch area lighting
up very harshly as soon
as you touch the slightest
corner of it.
This softens that out a
little bit for your users.
CHET HAASE: So
there's a new class
called RippleDrawable
that enables this.
And this basically
wraps the content
that you want to display and
then reveals that content
over time with the
ripple, and then
you optionally have
a color that you
can set as well to change
the properties of the ripple.
This comes
automatically built in
into a lot of the standard
widgets like buttons
you'll see this in the
applications that are enabled
with material design already,
or you can use RippleDrawable
directly, either from code
you can instantiate it,
or you can do this in XML
resources, or an easy way to do
is you can set the foreground
or background of something
to be a selectable
item background,
and that will automatically
ripple that selection
interaction.
So we had some changes in icons.
We had some new stuff added.
There were a couple of these.
One was state
animation drawable,
which is the ability to actually
animate through different PNGs.
You can think of this
as key frame animation
where we're just flipping
through different images
along the way.
The check box and the
radio button, I think,
in the L preview
release represent this.
So if you've seen any of
the demos of that so far.
If you want to actually
flash the system image,
you'll see those widgets
interacting through this.
It's basically a way for us
to animate from state to state
through the series of
images along the way.
And the other one was
stateless animator.
The ability to say, OK,
when this widget goes
from this state to
that state, here's
this arbitrary animation
that I want to run.
In general, you would give
it object animator animations
as you see here, we're
stacking up three of them
in an animator set.
We're saying, OK,
I want to animate
the following
properties on my object
when I go from the
pressed to the unpressed
state, and back and forth and
to different state combinations.
So a much more flexible
way of saying, here's
the behavior that I want
this widget to go through
as it goes from
state a to state b.
ADAM POWELL: So
what's an example
of where someone might use that?
CHET HAASE: For instance,
popping a button up.
If you want to have a press
state for when you click
on the button-- that sounded
like a canned question.
It wasn't.
I wasn't expecting
you to ask that.
Like why are you making
me think up here?
So if you want a button to set
its elevation property when
someone presses on
it, then you can
set an animation to do that.
So when it gets into
the press state.
It says, I'm going
to the press state.
Here's an animation
that I need to run
and then you would animate
the translation z property
from say zero to 20.
And then when it goes
back to its base state,
you would animate
from 20 back to zero.
Animation.
Let's talk about animation.
So there were various
things introduced
in the preview
release, which you'll
see in completely
different areas.
And we'll sort of build
up to the largest one.
The reveal animation we've seen
in some of the floating action
button demos in the
previous talk for instance,
as well as other interactions
that are up to you
in your application
is the ability
to define an
expanding shape that
reveals the content
underneath it,
like a circular reveal,
or you can combine
this circular, this animated
circular shape with a more
complex shape of
your view to get sort
of a rounded wrecked
effect or whatever.
Basically, you say
create this animation
that is a circular reveal.
It's going to be centered
here, and the radius
is going to animate from
this value to that value.
And then you start the
animation and you go.
So very simple way to
create an animator.
It's kind of an
opaque interface.
There's not a lot of
flexibility there.
Again, given the constraints
that we're under actually
make these things performance
on the types of hardware
that we have.
We limit these capabilities
to the specific use cases
that we find are important.
So you can do what
you need to, but it's
going to be limited to this
set of capabilities for now.
The important thing
to realize though
is that some of these
things can be expensive.
So one of the things
that we wanted to do
is not make it super easy
for you to just create
this arbitrary
clip on your shape
and leave it there all
the time, because that
is incredibly expensive.
The way that we implement
this stuff through the GPU
is not trivial.
So we're going to run
an animation over time
and then it's going to
be done, and we can just
be back to rectangular views,
because frankly that's easier.
So it is expensive.
We expect you to use these
in very transient situations
where you're just
animating a thing,
and then you back
out of the animation.
You can get a similar
effect on previous releases.
If you've used the
search on the Nexus 5--
and the KitKat
release did this--
they had a circular
reveal to show
some of the search results.
There are ways to
do this already.
Again, there are
performance issues there,
and you need to figure
out whether that actually
works for your application
and your situation.
But you can already do
it with drawing shapes
with bitmap shaders.
Animation curves.
So one of the things
that the designers
as well as the engineers
wanted in this release
was the ability to have more
arbitrary time interpolation.
So we already have the ability.
In fact, the default
behavior of all animations
is ease in ease out.
So we have a subtle
acceleration.
And then a subtle
deceleration out of it.
And you can tweak how
magnified those effects are.
And there's other things you
can accelerate all the way in.
You can decelerate
all the way out.
But once you get past
those, that's it.
And designers
really like to think
of things in terms
of curves instead,
quadratic and cubic bezier
curves and the ability
to tweak the parameters
to get exactly
the kind of timely
behavior they need.
So that's what we
implemented in the platform.
And in particular, there's
three animation timing curves
that they recommend as
part of material design.
And you can see these here.
They define these with
particular curve parameters.
I put the file names
down at the bottom.
So these are resources
that you can simply
refer to as interpolators
in your animations,
or you can actually set
the parameters arbitrarily.
So you can see that here.
There's an XML resource that
you can define to do this
or you can access
the code directly.
You're basically working
with a unit square.
This is sort of a traditional
animation and graphics way
of defining things.
You have a unit square
from zero zero to one one.
You can think of the
control points being
at two corners of that square.
Those are the anchor
points, sorry.
And then you define
where the control points
are to vary that
curve along the way.
In fact, you can have a
much more arbitrary path.
Because we're actually doing
a full on path in there.
It's not even just
a single curve.
You can define a complex path.
I don't know why you
would, but you can.
We also have the ability
to curb motion now.
You can already do this.
I wrote a blog post, I don't
know, two or three years ago,
talking about how you can use
type evaluators to move things
along in a spatial curve.
It was not easy, which is why
I wrote a blog post around it
and explained it.
And you can certainly
still use that approach.
But we also wanted to
enable an easier way
to do this through the API.
And now you can.
There are new constructors
in Object Animator that
will allow you to specify
the path that you want
an object to follow as it moves
along animating both x and y as
part of the same animation.
So there's a path animations
demo in API demos.
If you check out the
SDK, check out that demo.
And it'll show you different
variations on that theme.
Activity transition.
So this was a fairly
big effort that
built on the transitions API
that was introducing KitKat.
The idea behind transitions
is to make animations
much more easy and automatic.
They're still customizable.
But the big idea is I'd like to
know what state my UI was in.
And then I want to know
what state it's going to be.
And I want you to animate
everything in there, instead
of me creating custom
animations for everything.
So you snapshot where things
are at, and then you run layout.
And right before
it draws things,
you figure out where
things are going to be.
And then you roll
everything back
and you animate those
changes instead.
That's the way
transitions works.
And that's the API that
came out in KitKat.
And this is the way that
activity transitions now
work as well.
It builds on that
same model, but allows
you to have that same
way of specifying
animations between activities.
And not only that, not
only does it figure out
how to animate these things out
from the launch, the launching
activity, and how do
they animate the items
in on the launched
activity, but you can also
specify a set of
shared QUrl elements
that are then basically
thrown over the wire.
And said, OK, this
image was here.
And now it's going to be there.
And it's going to be
this different size,
and animate that
change automatically.
So we came up with a protocol
for defining, OK, here's
the name that we're
defining for this thing.
then the activity
on the other side,
if it knows what
that name is Ken
make some assumptions about
that being the same element then
that element is shared across
and animated automatically
through activity transitions.
ADAM POWELL: So the summary
for that is essentially
that this now gives you
a way of establishing
a protocol between
different activities
that may or may not be part
of the same application
to share a particular
element in a transition
from one to the other.
CHET HAASE: So
you can already do
this in your own
application, like if you
have a sub-activity--
say a details
view for some thumbnails.
There is a already
technique for doing this.
What we're doing is
making that less of a hack
and more codified
in the framework
APIs to allow you
to do that more
easily inside your application.
Not only that, but
through the protocol
we've established with the names
of the shared hero elements,
you could actually do
that across processes.
You could end up launching
somebody else's activity.
And if they know what to do
with that shared hero element,
then they can take part in that
activity transition animation.
If you want know how to do
it on previous releases,
if you're trying to
do this everywhere,
there's a dev bite on it called
customer activity animations.
And you can think about
the technique that's
used there as basically being
baked more into the framework
as a first class citizen
of how to do it for real.
ADAM POWELL: Right.
And this will take care of a
lot of the really tricky bits
around the activity
life cycle itself.
If your activity gets
restarted, make sure
that you're not replaying
another intro transition
animation that you don't want to
see again, so on and so forth.
CHET HAASE: So here's
some of the code.
There's actually a lot more
APIs than code involved,
especially when you
start customizing things.
But just to give
you an introduction
to how you enable these
things and how you actually
start these
animations-- so you can
put this item in
your theme, you can
define a style that says I want
to enable these window content
transitions or you can do
it in code-- very similar.
And then you can either just
use the default animations which
you're going to cross fade
between activities-- just
a simple fade out
fade in, or you
can set custom transitions,
either ones that you define,
or ones that the
platform gives you,
like I want an explode
transition which
shoves everything out off the
top and the bottom of the sides
of the screen.
And so you can set these
customs for the exiting activity
as well as the
entering activity.
And then finally you can
define what the shared element
set is that you're
passing over the wire,
give it names, pass it
over, and then define
what the transition animation is
that happens on those elements
as well.
We have a demo in a minute.
Finally, I want to mention that
there are new transitions that
were written as
part of this work.
These are available for
transitions in general.
There's the ability
to move image.
It's a lot more flexible.
Image view can be
a little bit cranky
when you're trying to
resize it along the way
and this has some capabilities
to allow you to do things
in ways that you probably want
to, if you're scaling or moving
images around on the screen
as part of these transitions.
Sliding effect is to slide
things in and out to the right
and left.
Exploding is exploding the items
out with this staggered delay
so you get a nice effective
things gradually moving off
the screen and a couple
other transitions as well.
But let's take a
look at a quick demo.
If we can switch
to the demo device.
Back out of here.
So this is an API demos.
This is just a simple demo
that shows some of the how-tos.
So the items that I'm
clicking on, obviously
are the thumbnail images
that the end up launching
this other activity
you're going into.
They share that as
the shared elements.
You can see the other
images animating out,
and then the list items,
the text animating in
on the other activity.
And then this is
a demo there was
written as part of another talk.
At 2 o'clock will go
into more of the details
and some of these
graphics goodies.
And again, you can see
as we press on this thing
that it launches
this other activity.
And we go into the
second activity,
sharing the thumbnail, sharing
that bitmap images the data
that's being passed over
for the shared hero element.
If we go back to the slides.
Take it away.
ADAM POWELL: So the
takeaway for this talk
is that we're going
to provide you
with the material
look and feel for all
the basic parts of
the framework, all
the buttons and check
boxes, and everything else.
We'll give you the
ability to theme these.
So you can go ahead and apply
your branding colors to these
without having to auto
generate a lot of extra assets
within your application.
But that's really not enough.
What you really need to do is
to work with your designers,
work with the
design guide itself.
And you're still
going to be writing
a lot of custom code
in your application.
Because the parts that make
your application really
stand out and be different are
the parts that we can't write
for you or else they're going
to be the exact same things
that every other
application does.
What we want to do
is make sure that you
have the tools
available in order
to make those really unique
experiences for your users.
CHET HAASE: Resources.
So there's few resources
that are worth mentioning.
You've probably seen
this one already.
There is a design spec.
Is it there?
There's a link off the
d.android.com to a bunch
of this information.
And you certainly want to check
out the preview site itself.
Get the SDK.
Build against it.
Get the system images
flashed onto to your device.
Play around with it.
I would also suggest if
you're interested, especially
in the graphics and animation
part of what we talked about,
you can come to a talk at 2:00
PM that coincidentally has me
on stage again with [INAUDIBLE].
And we'll go into all are more
technical details about how
some of this stuff
works and how it might
be used to create these
kinds of applications.
And finally, oh there's
a feedback URL again.
And we actually have
some time for questions.
So there are a couple of mics.
Find a mic out there and
fire your questions at us.
ADAM POWELL: Come on up.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So quick question.
I want to know how
we're going to be
able to access this in
previous versions of Android.
I know I can look
that up obviously.
But I want to know
how much of this
is supported in the
Support Library,
and which version of
the Support Library.
ADAM POWELL: So there's a new
version of the Support Library
out with the Preview
SDK right now
that's going to make
some of this available.
But really the preview
SDK is more about
showing you some of the new
APIs in their natural habitat.
And for a lot of
other reasons, you're
probably not going to want to
let some of the apps linked
against the preview
SDK out into the wild,
just because it's
going to be involving
a lot of other pre-release API.
That being said, once
the final SDK version
is available you'll see that the
app compact library and others
will have some of the back ports
of some of the visual styling
that's available.
And we're going to
continue offering things
along the lines of CardView
to do very specific use cases,
and then things
like RecyclerView
that will allow you to bring
that kind of motion everywhere.
Now things like the
activity transitions
that Chet spent some
time talking about,
that you're probably not
going to have available.
So we're probably going
to just go ahead and have
some simple fall backs that you
probably already know and love
there.
CHET HAASE: It's also
important to note
as it came up
earlier in the talk
that a lot of what
we're talking about
is an approach to design
that you can then implement
using standard
Android programming.
Some the new animation
capabilities,
if they're not part of the
APIs on the earlier platforms,
you can't use them.
But there are other
ways to achieve
those kinds of
effects in many cases.
And some of the measurement, the
layout, the colors, that stuff,
you can get stuff to
look very similar.
It's just going to be a little
different approach for some
of the new animation
capabilities in particular.
ADAM POWELL: That's right.
The microphone in the back.
AUDIENCE: Can you hear me?
CHET HAASE: Yes.
ADAM POWELL: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Good.
So in the keynote and in some
demos that I've been seeing,
I've noticed that there's been
a movement to circular image
views.
Is that going to be available
widget for us to use?
ADAM POWELL: Yes.
I don't remember if we made
it just a simple drawable
or an actual view, but we've
got a component in the Support
Library that we'll
go ahead and apply
that circular clip
to your images.
CHET HAASE: There's
a rounded bitmap
drawable in the Support Library.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah,
I think that was it.
CHET HAASE: Is that what
you were talking about?
Yeah.
It's fairly simple.
We did not create a floating
action button or a fab widget,
because it's pretty darn simple.
It's basically an
image view where
the thing that your drawing
is a circular image.
Fairly straightforward.
You set an elevation on that.
You tell us what the outline
is and we do the right thing
with it.
It's similar for
CardView actually.
I want to mention this.
It's very easy to actually
get a CardView effect.
In fact, the demo that we're
going to show in a talk
later today, I just implemented
using a standard view
that I clicked and I
shadowed appropriately.
It was straightforward.
The advantage of us baking
it in into a specific widget
is, at least we have standard
padding and layout, and also
the ability to have
that similar look
and feel on earlier releases.
So that seemed worth creating
a widget for, the fab,
not so much.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHET HAASE: Yep.
AUDIENCE: So the activity
transactions and everything
are really nice and definitely
solve a common pain point.
What I wanted to know is if
there's a need support for that
for fragment
transactions and things
going across
fragment boundaries?
ADAM POWELL: Yes.
I don't believe it made it
into the Preview as of yet.
CHET HAASE: Yes.
Not yet.
But yes.
As soon as we solved the
really hard problem which
was activity transitions,
the next step
was fragment transitions.
So I would look for that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHET HAASE: Yup.
ADAM POWELL: In the back.
AUDIENCE: He had
the same question
I did for activity tran--
but we can see expect
to see that in another
preview release maybe?
CHET HAASE: I don't
know what the timing is
of other bits coming out.
I would just say expect
to see that in L.
AUDIENCE: But you're
working on it?
CHET HAASE: Yes.
ADAM POWELL: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: So now that we're
having these elevation
transitions for objects,
implies manipulability
of things on the screen.
Are there any improvements
to drag and drop
coming into L as well?
ADAM POWELL: What
kind of drag and drop
are you looking
for specifically?
AUDIENCE: Reordering
collections arbitrarily.
ADAM POWELL: Oh I see.
AUDIENCE: Nice event interface.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah.
So one of the things that
RecyclerView let's you do
is it lets you apply some item
touch listeners that basically
it lets you handle touch at
the level of the collection,
rather than the level
of specific items views.
So you don't have to perform
a lot of the translation back
up to the parent
and then back down
to specific points
in space for that.
So hopefully that'll
be much easier.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
That's exactly what
I was hoping for.
Thanks.
CHET HAASE: In the back.
ADAM POWELL: In the back.
AUDIENCE: Does it
makes sense or is it
even possible in existing
code to change ListViews
to RecyclerViews?
ADAM POWELL: So they're
largely compatible.
There's just two
key differences.
First is that if you are used
to cursor adapter and the way
that it splits out create
and bind view into two
different steps,
this is the default
state of being in RecyclerView.
So as long as you can
split out those components
of your GetView from your
ListView adapters right now,
then that's one
easy thing to do.
The next piece is, like
I mentioned before,
being able to supply
richer notifications
about the nature of
a data set change.
So without getting
those sorts of signals,
rather than just a
very coarse grained
notify data set change
call, then we're
not going to be able to do quite
as much with the animations.
AUDIENCE: Is that the
only benefit then?
Is the--
ADAM POWELL: Which?
The animations?
AUDIENCE: The richer
notifications.
CHET HAASE: It's newer.
It's cooler.
ADAM POWELL: It should
be obvious, right?
I guess I don't quite
understand the question.
So from some of the stuff
that we talked about before,
we've got-- do you mean benefits
of switching over the adapters
or switching from like a
ListView to a RecyclerView
for what's essentially
the same UI?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ADAM POWELL: OK.
Yeah.
If ListView is still meeting
your needs, then by all means
don't do any more work
than you already have to.
This is mostly to address
the needs of any UIs
where you really want to
be able to do much more
intricate motion and
intricate touching
or action with your items or if
you want to do custom layouts.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: What do you guys
think about the relationship
between these new
styles and basically
how it relates to overdraw
and battling overdraw?
Because from my point of view,
it seems not overdraw friendly.
ADAM POWELL: Do you want to
talk about some of the work
that we were doing with some of
the drawing command reordering.
Because I think that
some of that comes in.
CHET HAASE: Yeah.
We wear many hats
in the Toolkit team.
And one of them is
all about performance.
So there was a lot of work
done in previous releases
about optimizing display
lists and eliminating overdraw
as much as we can automatically
actually in the framework.
So it used to be the
case that if you had,
let's say a view
that was completely
obscured by another view
that was larger than it
and completely opaque, we're
going overdraw that thing.
Because we don't
know what's going on.
If you want to draw that,
OK, we'll draw it for you.
And all of sudden
you have 2x overdraw
without doing anything.
So now we can actually
eliminate that,
because we do some post
processing on the display list,
so we don't draw the thing
as completely obscured.
So there's a lot of
intelligence going
into this playlist
optimizations already
to avoid some of
those situations.
I would agree that more
animations and more rich
graphics on the
screen probably means
that you need to be
aware of what's going on.
If you're having fading
in translucent effects
all over the screen
all the time,
then yes, we will be
drawing more pixels
than if you didn't do that.
But it's kind of a standard
Android programming technique,
like be aware of
what's going on screen.
Use the tools that are there,
like the overdraw detector
to actually show what's
going on at the pixel level
and make sure that you're not
tripping over those hazards.
ADAM POWELL: In practice,
we've seen a lot of teams
start building their
material UI so far.
And by and large, their
overdraw situation
hasn't changed a whole lot
from their previous designs.
Again as soon as you
start introducing
fully opaque background,
sliding over other things.
If you start doing
a lot of stacking,
then yes, there's
cases where you're
going to want to start thinking
about the overdraw a little bit
more and what you can
to avoid the clipping.
We're definitely trying
to do as much as we can
in the framework to
do that automatically.
AUDIENCE: I guess
from my perspective
it's more of the design
principles everything
feels like it's stacked.
And in order to
accomplish that, you're
going to have to stack
things some times.
And is there a good
way to get around that?
CHET HAASE: Stacking is
more of a transient state.
I haven't seen a lot of UIs
where the things are full-time
stacked on top of one another.
ADAM POWELL: Well,
there are some
of the things in
the Google Now cards
that will stack on top of one
another and so on and so forth.
But even some of those,
what they've started to do
is you'll notice that
some of the cards
start merging together
into a single card.
If it's part of a
collection, it then
breaks out in some
of the detail views.
And I think that some of that
was shown in some of the demos
as well.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
CHET HAASE: And it looks
like we have two seconds left
for questions, which means
that we're all out of time.
Thank you very much.
ADAM POWELL: We'll be
over here if you wanted
to ask some other
questions afterwards.